okay hi everyone
we are going to do a design review of
some discrete
computation for version 13 of orphan
language
all right let's see roughly what we have
to talk about here this is oh my gosh
there's a lot of stuff here yeah it's
going to take us a few rounds
okay it's a lot of content this time
all right let's look well that's good
that's done that's not bad
okay graph isomorphism
right uh
is that a new algorithm or what
but i mean so
the subgraph part
is a new set of functions
the
isomorphism part is
performance
uh
okay
new libraries new new algorithms
fine subgraph isomorphous that's the
mapping i mean do we have a find
graphism or we do here did we have a
find graph isomorphism before yes
um
which which shows the actual mapping
yes
of um
the permutation basically i mean fine
graph isomorphism returns a permutation
basically
it returns a list of rules
at association
um
where what find
excuse me
oh it is now an association so wait a
minute this when it says find graph
isomorphism it's finding all
isomorphisms is that correct
oh i see it's some number of
isomorphisms
when is this function from why haven't i
used this function oh my gosh
all right okay okay okay
i could have used this function for all
kinds of things why did i not pay
attention to this function
because we have yeah we have hypergraphs
we have some isomorphism binders like
this
okay what's new
is there new functionality or is this
just new performance for all these
things
sub graphics and more from this new
functionality
okay
so
how much i mean eventually we need to do
graph rewriting and we have all kinds of
code from the physics project for graph
rewriting
and i mean i don't know
okay i mean subgraph isomorphism is very
close to graph rewriting obviously
right guys it's yes it's one piece yes
what key piece right
i mean then there's all this whole
double push out nonsense
um
okay
find isomorphic subgraph
i see
wait find isomorphic sub graph
i see returns the actual sub graph with
the labels so you can actually highlight
that sub graph for example yes
okay
um
how much better is isomorphic sub i mean
graph find isomorphic graphq
did it get much faster
yeah we
significantly faster especially in the
range i mean it's not yet in the
prototype build we put it but you know
especially in the large range of uh
you know ten thousand on and higher
where actually right now we can't
while it's you know
this is a new library right
um mix code
see it's a mix code of that
bestie based on the base not t
right
i thought there was a new new approach
other than norte
well it's pretty much rely i mean it's
pretty much the same thing but it's just
different type of implementation
i see
okay
look
on graph rewriting
we probably should have a session
with the folks involved with the physics
project who worked on graph rewriting
um
and um
to nail what you know what the design
should be and so on because we you know
we've done a lot of thinking about that
makes sense yep
because
with subgraph isomorphism you're
basically there in terms of the
algorithmically difficult part of graph
rewriting
um okay
a question from ethan on our live stream
what about progress monitoring
for some of these things is it relevant
or are we are we is are they fast enough
that we don't need it or
or
what
i mean you can always take an infinite
amount of time but i don't think we
really want to put the effort of putting
a progress monitoring here
but does it is it i mean
if graph isomorphous is going to work or
is it going to work fast or is there a
case where graph graph isomorphism works
but it's really slow
well i look at in term of uh complexity
in terms of the number of vertices for
example so
up to range of you know
ten thousand or a hundred thousand you
still need you know
decent seconds and such so
you said 10 seconds at 10 000
it should be in the range of 50 seconds
i mean in that range of 10 seconds or
less
okay implementation
yeah okay guess the other question is if
it's if it's using some library then it
might not be very easy to add progress
monitoring right it's just spending its
time inside some library function
i mean even normally even if you are not
choosing i mean doing the progress
monitoring is costly will actually make
the whole like you know implementation
slower right
anyway
presumably
um
parallelization i don't think that's
relevant these algorithms are not
readily paralyzable
i mean the the um
um if we're doing
you know searching a graph
from this
you know database of graphs so to speak
by the way well this is probably a wrong
meeting for that but you know don't you
think we should have a parallel select
yeah
i mean
this thing of having parallel versions
of everything i think we should
well maybe it should be like a headdress
or something instead of
having 75 functions yeah absolutely
chris i mean yes
yeah but but also i think the reason why
paraselect is a bit different is that
with things like parallel map parallel
table if you know the result for element
72 comes in you know before the result
for element 70
you know where to insert it right but
you don't for select because you don't
know how long it's going to be
right that makes sense that's true no i
mean it has to be a bag of some kind
that it puts things into can somebody
add that to the um
presumably i'll d agenda to talk about
parallel select i've needed it a zillion
times and what i end up having to do
is some weird
you know
mess with parallel table
and then picks and things like that
um
so you do select for each subtable or
something no what i'm doing is i do
parallel table or parallel map
get a bunch of trues and falses
and then do a pick
right use pick to pick from the original
list
but how do you get it parallel
because the parallel map is parallel in
other words if the operation that is
doing the selection test is expensive
then is
without ever generating all of those you
know in the case where i have a very
large number of cases to look at i don't
want to have to regenerate all those
cases right
okay
anything else we need to know about
these these these ones here so i'm
assuming that molecules i don't think we
have a representative of the molecule uh
team here but this question about
molecules as graphs and how easily you
can take a molecule object and do graph
operations on it can you
yeah if you do graph of a molecule you
get a graph
among other things
it's just as it it just has a
constructor i mean is where we limit
ourselves so
you know
if you take a molecule you ask the calf
will return you the car but we limit
ourselves there we don't manipulate
molecule in the whole framework
women so if i say
molecule
you know caffeine or something
and then i say um
uh i mean and then you're saying if i
say this and then i say graph of that
no that didn't work is that new in 13
yeah
okay
yep you should work okay hold on let me
just see that that was i'm running in
12. yeah that would explain it
yeah okay fine okay you you made it
sound like this was a well-known thing
no no we pushed through a bunch of
things sir now
okay all right i know that we talked
about that recently yeah you see that
like graph extensions down there it says
graph updated construct graph just from
molecules tree
okay okay okay okay oh there we go cool
now why is that see i think we talked
about this before i think that should
use um
the coordinates i don't see any reason
not to use the coordinates that you get
from molecule plot
i really think we should
you see what i'm saying
charles any objection to that
um
[Music]
um
well we'll try the theme
there's probably a reason why it was not
done so we'll think about it i think it
just wasn't thought of
wait a minute oh no
i just put a bunch of hydrogens in there
yeah no no i was just
well there is a question about the 3d
coordinates versus the two no
right
what
no no i just remember why because the i
mean the new implementation we are using
uh the code from json the original
implementation we actually generate with
the coordinate
right so i'm saying preserve the 2d
embedding i mean you could in principle
preserve the 3d embedding but i think
that will be a mistake
i think you should preserve this
diagrammatic embedding what about the
double bonds why are those not showing
up as as um
as double edges
that's an annotation
disgusted with the chemistry people no
they shouldn't
never mind they shouldn't
i mean i'm about to care extremely much
about this molecules as graphs thing
because i have a whole brand new theory
of of
well maybe it's a new theory of
molecular dynamics i mean immaculate
biology
here's the key insight which might not
be
oh never mind well you look at these
reaction networks
which have dynamics
and i claim there's information stored
in the dynamics of the network that is
different from the information stored in
individual in in concentrations of
molecules
anyway different differences that's what
our biochem library deals with from
system modeler
which aspect of it pathway i mean it's
it's it
deals with
modeling and quantitatively simulating
pathways or reaction networks
oh i should look at that i had no idea
we had that
yeah
it's called systems biology
i know this field name but but you mean
you mean an hour
but we have we've built a library the
system on our team built the library
many years ago it's free
that allows you to model those
i remember that for some pharma you know
used by some pharma companies exactly i
hadn't internalized
i mean how accurately does it model the
reactions very the problem is how much
data is available to um
you know a chemistry team know about
this
yes we've had that discussion
actually we've iterated between uh them
and us yes
they do okay all right okay and and
you know these beautiful graphs that you
see are reaction networks they're
usually just graphs they don't have
quantitative data so the question is how
do you add the quantitative data so you
can actually know reaction rates and so
on which matters
sure
well i mean that but that's
the same sort of type of other kinds of
refinement of let's say that you have a
food web
those are just structural but there's
actual rates there there's sort of you
know cod you know herring at a certain
rate
you know right
i mean my claim is that there's actually
another level of that but anyway that's
not that's not yes let's not forget
let's meet
um
okay
find vertex coloring
that's interesting
okay so if i do this and i say
find vertex coloring
of
that
oh very nice
cool
so
oh that's very cool
huh
does it work for non-planar graphs where
it might have to give you know
seven numbers oh that's really cool i
guess
yeah as opposed to maps
which are planar graphs if you like um
there's no bound you know think about
the
um
the degree of a node of a vertex
there's like no way that you can get
away with less than the degree number of
colors
right
is that surprising
that it requires only
um
not really because they you know they
are bound right it's bounded by
the size of the maximal click on the
degree
of vertices right
so if you compute the vertex degree of
your graph you can pretty much guess
already was the upper bound and lower
bound
i see
okay
but so if
i
well it's very cool okay
good
chromatic polynomial which we've had for
a while why is the what's the
relationship between the quadratic
polynomial and these um
chromatic numbers and so on
so the chromatic polynomial essentially
for each color give you the number of
possible coloring for each
so for each value of t you give the
possible number of coloring essentially
so it's a count of possible number of
coloring for your graph
what's t
so essentially t is the number of
coloring you want
right
okay i should look at vertex coloring so
this is this will tell you
um
this will tell you
uh you can give ask for multiple vertex
colorings right so there are many
because there may be many vertex
colorings
no there is
essentially vector scoring by one
argument give you the minimal so the
smallest possible number of color you
need
to color your so you so your claim is up
to
i don't quite understand that is is it
is it the case that's unique up to
permuting the color
labels
no i don't think so
so
this is just giving a particular vertex
coloring what if i wanted different
vertex coloring
so what we are returning
is in terms of size of the coloring
right so there's the minimal amount
which is coloring which is invariant
from the isomorphism so if two graphics
are morphic
right because the neighbor will be
pretty much matched so the coloring will
match
well but i think that there can be i
mean can't there be uh
two colorings of a graph that are not
kind of where there isn't a similar sort
of automorphism or whatever
you know like
yeah right that's why we are returning
integer one two three because you could
apply any kind of permutation of one two
three no i understand that but what
christopher is saying and i'm saying as
well
is that list there
is there more than one possible list
independent of the one two three
so how do i get another possible vertex
coloring that isn't just related by
permuting the one two and three no they
will be permitted by they will be
dependent with permutation
wait a minute you're claiming that it's
a theorem that basically
the minimal coloring of a graph
there is only one way
to minimally color a graph
up to
the labels of the colors is that correct
clearly if it's a non-minimal coloring
there are a gazillion ways to do it
right you understand the question
no i'm not sure understand what okay
what i mean is this let's say i take
this graph okay and i say that's the
vertex coloring of that graph right
maybe an alternative vertex coloring is
1 1
one two
three whatever right in other words
something not
related by permutation of the labels yes
is that possible
yes but when it's minimal
my claim is that you'll be pretty much a
permutation
no but permutation on the labels yes on
deliverables okay but but pretty much is
not a theorem
well because
i will just essentially prove that there
will be isomorphic so endosomorphically
there's more efficiency pretty much the
label right when we talk about
isomorphism is on the label
but it's not obvious to me and there's
either is a theorem or there isn't a
theorem
so
i i found that i mean there's at least
there's a wikipedia page for uniquely
colorable graphs
you know which is talking about graphs
which have the property that
i guess the the weaker property that
that basically uh all colorings are just
there's only one coloring up to
permutation of the colors
but right which is what we're talking
about here but was you're saying the
fact that there's a page about that
means that there are many non-uniquely
colorable graphs
potentially although this is this is
also talking about for for k colors
right so that's not necessarily maybe in
the minimum
case it's special but
i don't think it doesn't
i i don't know i'm sort of
yeah it doesn't seem obvious that that
would be the case
i think it should be checked in other
words there's no need to say find me
another coloring
i also have the question is it would it
be useful to be able to say find a five
coloring of this graph or is that not
useful or is only the minimal coloring
of use of you you get that that's the
second argument
that's the second use case
find coloring
oh i say
okay so if i say this red green blue
and then i say
okay fine and now i say
graph of percent one comma vertex style
arrow percent it won't work we are
we are fixing that
it's one of the new extension so you
have to thread because we we do the
mapping from vertex you know vertex name
to color
but this is a feature we are going to
add so we can just take the list
okay and you're going to add that for
all the other vertex label and all that
kind of stuff
um
yeah where is possible
okay okay
cool
um
yes this is good it's very nice
okay
um
the question here ethan is saying can
you make coloring so that's what we're
doing here
you can use the
okay
um
okay all right that looks wonderful
very nice okay let's talk about planar
graphs
oh do we actually get to
answer questions like i mean given a
plane a graph
okay first of all how do i generate a
random plane of graph can i do that is
there a random plane a graph now
no no not yet
presumably it would be a
graph distribution also right like you'd
say random graph of blah blah blah
makes sense to me
guys
it's it's not for 13 we think so
isn't there an easy algorithm for
generating random planar graphs
yes you can do dylan image but the point
is you want a uniform distribution i
mean
the big challenge
the big advantage of what we did with
graph distributions is that we guarantee
that we fill out the space correctly it
has the correct measures so if you can
understand
if we just want to sort of do a hacky
function that generates some of them
that's easier well let's make sure
there's at least one in the function
repository for random planar graphs
right because otherwise we're going to
have a hard time
uh you know sandra is saying just make a
voronoi of some points
yeah so that's a hacky way yeah i mean i
looked into this at one point there was
no there was no like
famous algorithm for doing it although
there were i think a few papers and it
did seem like there were some
some ways to do it
there is there is a i mean there's a
bozeman sampler it's doable it's not
complicated it's a matter of
you will have it in 131 it's just a
matter of sitting and doing it so
there's a clear technique for doing that
so if i say
i mean just to make one just so that i
can play with these functions
um if i just say something like this
oops 10 comma
and then um
like 30 comma 2
okay and now how do i get the graph from
that mesh connectivity
okay planograph good okay
all right so now
oh that's useful plain a facelist let's
see what that does
give it the name since you're going to
play with it
i don't understand why they're pairs
there why not why aren't these faces the
vertex
you should say index graph of percent
14. because the vertex
very nice they're all triangles fancy
that
um probably except the outer boundary
which should be somewhere there
i don't see an outer boundary
yeah and that means the complement right
yeah it should be holding
counterclockwise
pretty much well
so the orders are also
sorry go ahead
i mean is it so you said that the orders
are guaranteed to be clockwise and
everything
um yes just in case you want to figure
out what's the author you know you know
was the outer boundary so it's
counterclockwise i think
nice
shouldn't the outer boundary be
shouldn't there be an option to drop the
outer boundary
i'm not sure you ever want to do that
well but
but if you just want
why wouldn't you just want the interior
pieces because you might be thinking
it's a conceptually infinite graph
i don't know anybody else excited about
dropping the outer boundary i haven't
seen any use case right
forget it
yes okay fine
um well that's very nice
okay oh the dual planar graph i see
from a planar graph so if i take this i
can say dual planar graph
and i should get a bunch of
nodes with them
i should have one big
multi-legged creature
okay nice why did that why did that come
out with giant node size node
why did that come up with giant nodes
charles
sorry i don't understand what you mean
by germ node
giant as in this
disk is big
why is that so much bigger than this one
here
see see the size of that node there
in the rendering
oh i see oh wait dude this
white something strange is happening
yeah excise in the computation
something setting vertex size
yeah automation to actually determine
the
the size of the vertex right so we need
to compute a default value so
something is going wrong okay not gone
sorry it is going wrong here right
yes it's not the best one
but it seems wrong i mean it's just some
mistakes well it might be just something
like that this graph has fewer vertices
you know we are not going we don't spend
time actually looking at the position of
the vet as computing that i mean it will
be costly so we
well you you're saying that this is
simply
um
uh where do i put these help where am i
putting these
so actually just as a connected question
i mean is there uh
is there logic to the vertex coordinates
here like are they at the centers of the
faces in the original graph or something
like that
yes
cool are we keeping that embedding right
charles are we are we changing
doesn't look right no no no we're not
keeping that embedding that no because
usually if you if you do that which is
the centroid of your face yeah the
layout is really strange i mean although
because like the outer boundary right
the outer boundary is gonna be sort of
it's got to be a curve for that to work
right so yes we decided not to do that
um there will be maybe we can you know
do the vertex you know vertex coordinate
inheritance probably later on to do that
also i think that there can be
situations where um
i think they're gonna be situations
where if you just use the centers um
the resulting and you know straight line
embedding the edges might cross
right but presumably you want you know
the dual is
also planar so you'd like to lay it out
in a way that sort of shows it's planar
right that's exactly what's happening
here okay this is running the planar
layout yep
i recognize it's it's footprint
i i really think you should look at why
those why those dots came out too big
just some some issue
okay um actually sorry does that mean
there's a new planar layout thing as
well because i know at least the main
old one was the was the one that like
shows up in a right triangle or
something like that
um i mean i think in version 12 also we
have the total embedding which
kind of readjust it a little bit so is
that one by default
okay
yeah this is a very this is a nice
okay all right let's go on here um
control flow graphs
by the way in this sorry in this thing
here
what other things have i wanted to do
with planographs
um
yeah i mean the plane of facelist is
definitely the thing i've wanted a
zillion times
um
is that enough is there anything else
one usually wants to do with planographs
actually sorry how do these functions
like how does planar facelist work if
the embedding of the input graph is not
like a straight line planar embedding
does it just create its own embedding
and then give you the faces and all the
guarantees about ordering and stuff like
that are kind of out the window
right so first is that why the you know
the embedding is not unique right for a
planner graph
right right so what we do is so if you
are you provide us an embedding and it
is you know we can it i mean we can
check that embedding is a planner we use
it if it's not planner we use the full
embedding
okay make sense
oh i see so this planar face list is
relative to
the default is relative to the embedding
that's given or you should say that here
yes
you should also say what the what the
clock-wiseness guarantees are
that make sense
yes um
okay
dominator tree graph what the heck is
that obviously we've got a spelling word
there
um did you report the spelling word by
the way
not yet
what is the dominator tree graph
[Laughter]
oh i guess my objective
okay how does this relate to like
transitive reductions and things
so the
so essentially the dominator vertex it's
uh
essentially the
the vertex the unique vertex such that
any part goes through that vectors to
which you know
you know a you know a specific set so
you know
so that's pretty much it so you have so
it's like a trification of the graph is
it's like that has to be the root of
some
to get to a given vertex you have to go
through this one exactly
um
by the way i see comment on the live
stream from ethan about
add a unit distance graph cue or find
the unit distance embedding
yes that has been a request from several
people will do that at some point where
essentially they want uh
the length of uh
oh yeah i've wanted that i've really
wanted that
i i had code to do that like 10 years
ago maybe you helped me with that
charles
maybe it was 20 years ago
um i don't know
um
ten years ago perhaps i don't know no it
must have won that i don't i don't know
anyway who knows but um
uh
but i mean that should be a graph layout
right yes
yeah it will be very useful
um
ethan is complaining about vertex label
collision avoidance
which i know
yeah we we will do
we will do a future focus
on more advanced label layouts
release we already did some improvements
we did yes
so if you if nathan and others didn't
notice it with all these
like when you do
um like a complete graph with labels it
use intelligent label placements
you know a grid graph etc those guys use
um have optimized label placements
right
sandra's asking is dual planar graph of
dual planar graph
the identity operation
no because it's gonna uh when you do the
dual planar graph it's going to make
this new embedding right
i mean certainly the embedding of the
graph you get back will be different but
probably it'll be but the graph itself
is isomorphic is it not
that's it's definitely isomorphic but i
mean it might be if you do three dual
planar graphs and then four and five
then it might just start going back and
forth because it's just the same graph
being fed to the uh
to the thing that's generating a plane
or embedding right
well here let's just do it just for fun
so we're just saying this
ggg let's say 10 steps
hey this is taking a while
why is this taking so long
help why is it taking so long
charles it's not a very big graph why is
it taking so long well because i mean
that's the cost of computing vectors
coordinate and validating
but is it taking a little bit too long
so
we'll check on that not sure
let's just try a smaller one
so i i bet if you say faceless like if
you if you did
two if you did a planar graph of tool
plane or graph and then you look at the
face list you'll probably get the same
face list as if you just ran face list
of uh ggg right yeah you should do
shouldn't you
well actually it's not obviously
yeah
um
this is labor saving or not
um let's see
planar
faceless
oh that's i didn't make index graphs out
of them
okay who knows the precedence of um
is that going to work or do i need
parentheses
no you don't need parentheses
well the theorem is not true
it doesn't look like it's true at least
okay well so so that isn't in fact the
case
um
okay
let's keep going okay so now this
dominator tree graph
um
[Music]
what what should we look at there i mean
uh how wait a minute let me look at that
so first the image immediate dominator
list gives you the you know the
immediate
of each vertex
right and then the denoted graph
actually just gives you the whole
the actual three which represent that
so that has to be with respect to a
particular vertex yes
um
no
no no um no
it's probably because
this graph
is unknown oh it's why do you just work
on directed graph
oh
um okay
so if i say
how do i make this a directive graph let
me just say what happens
while you put the edge on both sides i
guess
oh that's boring because it's just that
then if i said simple graph would simple
graph
what will it do no it'll be confused
um
i don't know give me a nice way to make
a simple
make a a just do random graph directed
edges arrow true
okay
i think you should actually even remove
the second argument you should give you
the full list
okay
well we should probably do the one
argument form
what would the one argument form do it
would give a list of lists yes for all
of them
what does that mean what does that list
that i just got out mean
that means
for each
i don't understand what is that
listening
immediate dominators of the director of
graph from the root vertex v
wait
so
this is the things which are the
predecessors yes
that's a very weird name this immediate
dominator thing
um
is is it basically the reversal of
i don't understand
what what if there are two feeders into
a given vertex what is the dominator in
that case
this is what feeds into a given vertex
true or not true
when you say feed yeah it's it's in
vertex right i mean it's what you mean
but it's the vertex in component if i
look at the vertex end component in
percent 27 i say vertex
um
in component
of um percent 27 comma two for example
yeah i get four there right this is the
thing that feeds in right if i say the
end component of three
i'll see the the immediate and thing
will be
okay now i'm confused
why is there a 17 there why why is the
17
the n component here okay vertex in
graph is that what it's called
no what's it called vertex that is graph
component
vectors of component
and graph component
no what do you what what is it
what is it called
vertex
what
what do you say
vertex well myself i don't remember the
name now it's um
isn't it with graph i'm pretty sure it
ends with graph
yes it is
and it should help
vertex
in
well this should have that name yeah
yeah yeah so it's vertex in component
graph right
okay well why isn't it listed on the end
component why is it listed on both it
should be it should be okay
bluff okay let's see if i say i just say
to level two for example level three
okay so this is saying
going into
three here
y is 17
i am totally confused
why is 17 the immediate dominator
of 3
why isn't it 34
i don't even understand how 70 even gets
there
right 17 has to go through four steps to
get there
can we return to this one next time and
our documentation will be i
the clear example in the documentation
i'm not sure i kind of trace down what's
happening especially that you have on
the right edge right different direction
which can afford affect the
right we'll pick it up again
okay um
okay
oh that's cool
graph objects from binary tree
okay
oh that's cool too
works on tree expressions okay so if i
say random tree
of 50 for example then what you're
saying is if i say find shortest path
of
that random tree percent 34
from let's say 10
to 26.
what
that doesn't look right
look there's there's 10
there's wherever it was 26 was somewhere
here
there why doesn't it do it
it is
what is the name
of your so when you do the random t
what's the vertex list
yeah from now with the vertex
that's a bit confusing
so
you can have you can have the same label
appearing in multiple places in trees
that's one of them oh that's right
that's one feature of a tree
so i think it's it's the label comma and
then the position here right
no we we don't handle pattern you define
for this part
okay so if i pick
i mean basically
to get a path and that's also very weird
if i might say so that the vertex list
is not sorted in order of the tree
ordering and some kind of lexicographic
tree ordering
it might be in the reverse tree ordering
because i think 34 is the root
yeah but it's not because where's one
why is one one not
appearing
i think it's depth first
oh gosh
well that's interesting in its own right
because i'm about to do this giant study
of of um uh
uh traversal orders okay we have a big
thing coming up in our tree review
of traversal orders
oh really okay that's great yeah okay
okay
really when are we doing that review
because i want to see that i don't know
it's it should already be scheduled i
just don't
it's like a big blur of design reviews
coming up
okay
order option or what yes
well that's what we discussed great
um
oh i want to see that okay
um
okay so so vertex list will probably
have a traversal order then for trees at
least
but okay so this is just going to give
me in the end if i okay
yeah it's a thing for tree expressions
only
you know vertex list is thing for graph
presumably though like if you if you
apply if you say graph of a tree right
if you're converting a tree to a graph
you want to be able to specify
the traversal order that you're using
and then maybe functions like vertex
list that automatically do this
maybe should also take that option
um
no this this framework is a general
schema for graph not we shouldn't have
specific options for trees i think
that's the first thing uh second also we
respect actually i think
there is the new function in three we
call it word craft three or three graphs
which from the three you generate the
graph so essentially we respect that
structure on the very existence that's
what it's called tree graph
okay
that's cool that's really cool
um
okay
okay
i mean it's sort of unfortunate
and this is something for the trees
group and we should probably bring this
up in that tree's review that you can't
get something where it ignores the names
and just tells you the part numbers
which it after all knows for a tree
you see what i'm saying
i mean it's the shortest path from and
then you give it two part numbers yes
i
i think that would be useful for a tree
can we bring that up in the trees review
please
okay so tree graph there and so now
what's the vertex list of this
okay that's the same thing
right
i'm confused let's bring this system
all the functions that that that are
graph functions that take trees they
just call tree graph before they process
them
yes
pretty much
okay but i think it might make some
sense though for you know for them to
also
take tree graph options you know if
there are significant drew graph options
but
i i don't think he should charles is
pushing back on that but i'm not sure
he's correct about that but he doesn't
want vertex list which is a general
graph function to take things specific
to trees
right
find shortest to run should it take
things specifics to molecules too should
it take things specific to data
structure you know whatever we do well
so maybe then we need options in tree
graph to do the appropriate stripping or
something
yep so that's why it was the specific
constructor i believe it was added
for that
by the way when are we going to have
dags
that's just a question i mean now that
we've got trees
maybe it's time to do dags
um
let's see
um
okay so let me see these ones for data
structure that seems cool as well
um they're not just in the prototype
build so okay all right okay fine but
that's that's an extractor
if you give it a data structure
like if i give it a linked list
and i say graph of that will it give me
just a chain
no we stick on
the
data structure which explicitly
graph base but yes we can do that for
linked lists but
we stick for binary tree on evs yeah
okay fine
okay
are there any graph functions that you
might have thought will work for trees
that don't
like for example well graph plot
oh i see you can give a different
embedding if you want to
that is a very untree-like embedding by
the way when are we getting hyperbolic
embedding
oh
well there's still some work to actually
polish we have the layout but there's
still some performance issue on
improvement
because that's obviously very relevant
to the trees people
not not
okay fine but but i've got a question
which is this is if you look at the
the the list of things it's very
overloaded right now we can't
you know i'm not i'm not pushing roger
i'm just off it's coming no no it's
coming it's in the box okay but i'm
making a design point which is that in
the trees framework you might want
hyperbolic uh layout of a tree
and is there a way to d is there a graph
layout option to tree does anybody know
um yeah they've pretty much added all
the relevant graph options by now
that's one of the new things
do they look like trees or like graphs
though if you asked you know you'd use
graph layout like are the labels green
well i mean you have to be in that
review let's let's deal with that now
okay fine that's a different thing yeah
it's a different review okay well
actually we can answer that question
give me a layout
circular layout or something
let's do it in that i don't know if it's
in proto that's
okay fine
just just so long can somebody is
somebody taking notes here
can you make sure to have this who's
taking notes here yeah i'm taking notes
okay
scott here as well
yep hiding in the back
okay all right so can you make uh make a
note of that please make sure it's in
the trees
review
um
okay that's that's that's details of how
we're doing builds right isn't that a
new library were we using that one
before
yes
we were okay
okay let me look at some um comments on
the live stream before we move to
geometry
um
let's see
um
if you remember
okay if you permute the order of this is
a question from sander if you permute
the order of vertices does it always
give the same coloring
i would say the answer is probably no
making sense here if we permute the
vertices in here the names of the
vertices we always get the same coloring
that's the question that's the theorem
we don't know basically
we should we should answer that question
and we should say it in the
documentation whatever is true
what i say regard to the minimality but
we cannot guarantee that is exactly the
same colorway
so do the result that if you do a max
it'll always be b3 no i get it i get it
okay so we should just say that that
it's not a unique coloring
as long as we say that it's all good
right and if there's a condition where
it is the unique coloring who knows what
it is that's stateable we should state
it
does that make sense
okay we can try
i don't see how useful it is that's my
no no the reason i'm saying this
is look
you know let's say you are trying to do
any one of these things register
allocation okay let's say that you know
there's an additional constraint on your
registers which ones are nearby
which ones have you know have crosstalk
between them or who knows what else
right and you say that's nice that's a
register allocation coloring but what
about another one
right is there another one is there one
which will have which will where some
other constraint will work better i'm
making sense yes
and so i mean it's also maybe just as in
general but then that's a completely
different problem you're solving that
should be a completely different
function it's kind of what i mean here
there is a specific goal
something simple you are computing well
i know it's like find path versus find
shortest path exactly
right i'm just asking you the first
question is is there a theorem that says
there is only you know the shortest path
equals path and we're saying is probably
not
okay fine so then
then there is a question of multiple
vertex colorings
and how one might compute those and are
they worth computing
right so we just state in the
documentation it's not a unique vertex
color well
maybe also i mean there's maybe also the
question of
let me see i think we're a little
inconsistent with defined functions the
like for example would find path find
shortest path or like with find graph
isomorphism
you know even in the one argument case
fine graph isomorphism returns a list of
a single
isomorphism right
so like maybe if this function in the
future were you know took a second
argument where or i mean if it had some
some arguments where you could give work
give back multiple uh
you know colorings
then
it would we may regret the fact that
it's that it's doing one level list
well here the second argument i mean
there's a case where
you know it's not easy to find the
coloring but you don't want the minimal
color
right let's suppose you just want to you
know give you know you give a really
large vertex which if you want the
minimal we take 20 days
but you just say i want you know
you know a coloring with you know 10
color
so that's the girl of the second
argument and then we can find it really
fast and we give it to you
i mean i think the question is just like
if if in the future i mean
right i mean the point is just if
similar functions return it should be a
different function because i said the
goal are different
right right but if it's a different
function then maybe this function should
have a different name because this does
sound like the name of the function if
there was a function that returned many
things this would probably be its name
what does fine shortest path do doesn't
it just return one thing
yes it does find shortest path like this
is a one thing thing right
yeah is not
well but you're basically saying you
don't think it's super important to find
multiple vertex colorings and so if we
end up with another function
and it's also not super clear i mean
there's a bunch of things about
uh does it does it show you only the
colorings that are unique up to
permutation of the
colors or
you know etc
i mean
there is all variety of coloring we can
do all game we can do color here we are
fixing
you know there is a standard way
standard request and standard
application of coloring
right and is what is solving so we may
decide to change the name of the
function that's fine
but you know generalizing it to all
coloring problems i mean that's nice
okay yeah absolutely right i mean i'm
just wondering if maybe it should if
there's some word that could be inserted
into its name that would you know sort
of future future proof and we're using
coloring for historical purposes it's
sort of a stupid name because it's
really finding finite number of
assignments right
or labels for vertices yeah
so i think it's called coloring i know
it is
but it's it's it's sort of stupid
right
because there are infinitely many colors
there is not just finitely many colors
in the world
right
i mean i assume it doesn't make sense to
call it a fine minimal
coloring because with the second
argument you might ask for a coloring
that's not this is what people when you
talk about graph calling this is what
people
are looking i think this is going to be
okay
um
okay
there's a question about interacting
editing positions the vertices whatever
happened to that that um
uh that separate application that could
do that
why what
we had that weird java thing for a while
that did that
being able to edit the vertices vertex
positions
right i mean if there is a
house to coming soon which we just show
you you can just use locator right so
that's one one easy way
right the other way you can convert it
to a graphic and then use the graphic
editor yeah but then you can't get back
so wait a minute so you're saying we
have something coming which is an editor
is that true no we are just writing a
how to
just to show people how you can just use
locator
so you can you know set up the vertex uh
function of vertex shape with locator
and then you can move it inside the cuff
that's awful i mean
we should have a separate discussion
about this because there's some other
places in geometry and other other
things where we're starting to have more
of this kind of editing and with
molecules we have an editor obviously
right we have molecule draw
right can we
okay separate meeting discussion scott
can you please put it on the list yep it
won't be in the current cycle
um
let's see
what molecular grids i don't know what
molecular grid is
um
nick is asking if it's using the
embedding does dual graph place vertices
in the centroid of a face
no the answer is no
but could you could you ask it to do
that
um
yes so it's something we are considering
in term of in in everything so from
which we i don't think we implement it
yet we can say vector's coordinate goes
to inherited so we can irritate it from
the original graph
okay okay fine
that sounds like a good idea
um
richard says dominator trees are very
useful in compilation apparently llvm
has a class dedicated to them
yes yes
the suggestion came from tom
yup
um what what is it what is it used for
in compilation
this is
there's a number of um
i can't remember now actually actually
it's better that tom says you know but
it's it's one of these very base
um
but it it's for the single assignment
form right when you want oh i see right
right
you know i think my friend greg chetan
was the person who pointed out that um
register allocation is equivalent to
graph coloring i think that was one of
his heroic moments at ibm
um
let's see
uh
bob is wondering whether dual planar
graph takes more than linear time
we don't know
there was something fishy about what was
going on there
um
will code involving graph be compilable
in 13
that's a christopher question i don't
know if there's anything to say about
that yet
is there
uh i mean not in 13. i mean
this is irrelevant to this meeting but i
was playing around with basically
writing type signatures for graph
functions
just as sort of a test of the compiler
they're not for
for graphs
um but i don't think it's going to make
it in
fair enough
and and also those functions you know
pretty much all call the evaluator so it
doesn't help you very much
but it does help you when it has
wrapping around it that is
um compiler you know compilable wrapping
and the graph functionality itself is
pretty efficient i think
yeah
crucial made the comments says they've
made a package for dendroform algebra
it's a strange and different algebra
okay i don't know about that some kind
of tree related algebra
sounds interesting
um
okay question
sandra is saying look at maps of europe
are they colored the same that's an
interesting question
in other words this this whole question
we've been addressing here
there is presumably it is the case there
is no unique
forecoloring of the map of europe
it's not self-evident that that would be
which of that which of those things
would be the case
um
the
well one of the the the the horrible
secrets of maps is that the actual map
of country borders is not planar because
they're islands and their exclaves and
lots of crazy stuff
i'm gonna have to run
um well obviously we're gonna schedule
at least one more hour meeting
um hold on i just wanna see some of
these other comments here and then we
can
um
i'm going to find clicks which can
enumerate
i'll find coloring instance sander
suggests
find vertex coloring instance
is that a better is that better
i don't think it's particularly better
because like find shortest path there
might be more than one
um dan is suggesting graph setter which
is the future that's a decent name and
concept for this thing that you're
describing with them
uh with locators
um
okay dynamic graph plot yeah that would
be lovely uh edmund is saying dynamic
graph plot that uses locators behind the
scenes
um
okay richard is saying dominate on
post-dominated trees i don't know what a
post-dominated tree is it sounds like
it's probably the reversal of a
dominator tree perhaps
yes core tools used in numerous analyses
and transformations that allow us to
reason about the order of execution of
basic blocks and instructions
is to compute the dominance frontier
determining the optimal placement of phi
nodes
confirms safety of many transformations
like construction sinking and hoisting
it's interesting
sounds cool so that's interesting
actually that whole business that that
whole thing you're mentioning is is
relevant to things i'm thinking about
about
which amount to traversal orders
um
let's see
uh
okay nick is commenting for graphics
dragging is possible but resizing is not
possible currently with locators and so
on
that's an interesting comment that would
certainly be useful
um
okay we got a bunch of exciting stuff
coming here for geometry but it sounds
like we're not going to be able to get
to that oh this is really exciting stuff
oh very exciting stuff really have you
managed to get this to actually work now
the the 3d constructive cell geometry
yes
wowie
it's been 12 years or something hasn't
it
let's
it's going to be exciting so okay let's
look at it all right all right
cliffhanger yeah
okay all right um
just i just want to see what
oh there's many more this is just things
that we moved out that were on our
initial target list we have a much much
longer target list future
much
well this is wonderful stuff
all right we should probably wrap for
now um
and uh
look forward to the next one of these
hopefully scheduled soon
um and thanks to folks on the live
stream good suggestions and comments
much appreciated